merci beaucoup Michel Côté susciter
l'admiration grâce à son immense talent
mais aussi à sa grande humilité
si exceptionnel chez lui c'est au tail
c'est un immense acteur autant l'homme
était tout aussi exceptionnelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le comédien Marc Messier pleure le
départ de celui qui était son ami depuis
50 ans et qui s'est battu contre une
maladie de la moelle osseuse il fait
vraiment battu mais avec
une résilience
de tout essayé il y a vraiment tout
essayé ce que la médecine pouvait lui
proposer Michel Côté aura joué dans 25
films dont Cruising Bar ça soigne ta
maladie
Louise Marleau lui donnait la réplique
lui était vraiment fabuleux là il joue
quatre personnes très différents les uns
des autres on y croit complètement
c'est un super batteur
je vois toujours au cinéma Michel Côté a
souvent joué le rôle d'un père entre
autres dans Crazy et dans de pères en
flics qui est bien situé incarné le
drame mais il faisait l'inverse il
rajoute toujours une pointe de comédie
dans ce qui faisait une espèce de
toujours une bonne amie qui rendait le
personnage toujours sympathique on
sentait toujours le rire dans le fond de
son regard
les réactions sont nombreuses également
du côté politique Michel coté faisait
partie de du quotidien de millions de
maisons québécoises pendant des
décennies nous a fait rire il nous a
fait pleurer pour l'avoir rencontré
quelques quelques fois là c'est vraiment
aussi un homme extrêmement
sympathique donc nos pensées sont avec
Véronique le flaguet ces deux fils il
était touchant il était juste c'est un
homme qui a on avait envie d'être son
ami on avait le goût d'aller prendre une
Brou avec
Michel Côté aura marqué la culture
québécoise ils sont nombreux à vouloir
lui rendre ultime hommage
c'est vraiment un personnage unique au
Québec je crois vraiment un des
meilleurs acteurs qu'on a jamais eu une
cérémonie commémorative devrait être
annoncée prochainement ici Nabil
Alexandre Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal